here now is newt gingrich former speaker
of the house his new book beyond biden
is out on november 2nd and it's
available for pre-order now
uh newt um
i don't think that democrats have really
thought this through have they i mean
they thought these mandates is all going
to work they did some polling and they
put the polls out there people like the
mandates they like the mandates newt
until they can't get a police officer to
show up or they can't get a nurse on a
floor
if they're in an er
so then then the mandates don't look so
good do they
well look i think it's deeper than the
mandates you have a system
the american system which is falling
apart
uh you have hundreds of thousands of
illegal immigrants and by the way joe
biden doesn't do anything to apply his
fancy rules and his mandates to illegal
immigrants they don't get tested they
don't get vaccinated we don't check on
them for health reasons so somehow
american citizens can be punished by
their own government but people who show
up here illegally get flown around the
country get shipped around the country
get taken care of the taxpayers are
funding all the illegal immigrants who
are not required to do any of this but
there's something deeper going on they
can't unload the ships they can't find
the trucks they can't get the economy
moving uh they are cons they can't get
children educated go down the list
their system there's this entire big
government socialist system is falling
apart and their answer of course
is to use the power of the government
against the american people that's why
you have the attorney general trying to
sick the fbi on parents
who go to appeal to a school board
meeting i mean we've never not since the
civil war have we seen this kind of
intense
anti-citizen behavior
and this is happening because the left
knows they're a distinct minority they
know that the country is going to
repudiate them and they are desperate to
enforce on you and me and everybody else
their rules and what's beginning to
happen is you just saw in chicago
as we saw with southwest airlines
people are starting to figure out there
are more of us
than there are of these left-wing nuts
and i think you're going to see more and
more resistance on every front not just
in terms of the mandates yeah and and
newt i think biden
wants us to believe though that
everything is
going according to plan
we're headed in the right direction
we have critical work to do but we can't
let up now
my team and i are doing everything we
can
but i'm calling on more businesses to
step up
that's how we put this pandemic behind
us
and accelerate our economic recovery
newt is pressuring more companies to
impose these mandates going to help this
jobs uh crisis that we're in they these
companies can't hire employees
look when i hear joe biden talk about
plans
i think first of all about the
withdrawal from afghanistan which was a
disaster i think second about whatever
his plan is for the border where kamala
harris is absent without leave and it's
a disaster i look at the 60 ships that
are stuck off of long beach which is a
disaster i look at the they're already
starting to warn us that the joe biden
christmas is going to be a very narrow
lean christmas uh you look at the price
of meat which has gone up dramatically
the price of gasoline which has gone up
dramatically the number of jobs that are
unfilled
the number of trucking companies that
literally can't find truckers
and you look around you think if this is
the joe biden plan
it is a disaster
and i think all of us have to let let's
look at pragmatically
facts on the ground
not statements from the white house that
have no connection to reality newt we're
just hearing by the way tonight that the
fifth circuit court of appeals has ruled
in favor of allowing texas's abortion
law to go forward
which of course overturned that district
court
initial decision saying it couldn't go
forward uh so that is also good news for
the pro-life community across this
country and also uh a sign that
look they're they're in for a fight on
multiple fronts and they wanted these
culture wars by taking this decision
away from the people and they've gotten
these culture wars on their hands and
here we go probably headed to the
supreme court i think
look i think that's right on every
single front is right on the whole issue
of racism it's right on the whole issue
of law and order it's it's true in terms
of abortion and i think we're going to
have a very healthy national debate
about
what what is viability i mean the
original roe versus wade
has
totally obsolete now
because it's based on medicine that's uh
40 years old and no longer true or 50
years old it's no longer true so i think
this is going to be a period of time
when the american people come to grips
with themselves and what you find on the
left is that the big government
socialists basically are a religious
movement they're a secular religious
movement they can't deal with reality
they can't cope with facts if it doesn't
fit their narrative they just shrug it
off and refuse to pay attention to it
right and i just want to go back to one
thing i said earlier
if you're an illegal immigrant
none of joe biden's requirements apply
to you if you're an american citizen
he's willing to use the power of the
government to coerce you to force you
into losing your job if you're an
american employment yeah you're a second
class you're flying an airplane yeah
you're a second-class citizen that biden
is so pro-illegal immigrant and so
anti-american citizen hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else